et avec moi pour le grand entretien à
christophe robert bonjour vous êtes
délégué général de la fondation abbé
pierre merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
on va tout d'abord parler et bien de
cette crise économique social que l'on
voit déjà qui s'annonce alors avec
notamment ces chiffres de l'insee la
destruction de 500 mille emplois surtout
chez les intérimaires une récession de
11% une crise économique inédite
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec bruno
le maire qui dit le seul moyen d'y
arriver c'est d'accélérer dans la
reprise pour que la crise soit la moins
douloureuse c'est la seule issue
en tout cas il est clair que cette
situation extrêmement tendue sur le
front du de l'emploi et donc cette
hausse majeure du chômage nous inquiète
beaucoup la question de savoir si c'est
la seule issue
je crois pas c'est à dire que la
question qui se pose c'est celle qui
s'est posée d'ailleurs il ya eu des
actions dans ce sens là de la part du
gouvernement pendant la crise sanitaire
c'est de dire il faut éviter que des
gens par exemple du fait de cette
situation très tendue sur le front de
l'emploi ne bascule dans la grande
précarité donc ça suffit pas de dire
cela évidemment il faut tout faire c'est
la priorité absolue pour que l'emploi
reparte
c'est fondamental mais on sait très bien
que dans la situation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui beaucoup de
personnes ne vont pas retrouver un
emploi immédiatement beaucoup d'un
n'avait déjà pas avant la crise est là
la question des filets de sécurité des
protections sociales des mains tendues
reste évidemment essentiel vous l'avez
dit le gouvernement
en tout cas fait valoir qu'il a eu une
politique très protectrice à l'égard des
français sur la période du confinement
encore aujourd'hui la ministre de
l'économie se dit lui ouvert à la
distribution de chèques aux plus
modestes et ce qu'il a dit ce matin dans
ce contexte est ce que c'est une bonne
chose est ce que c'est pour vous
suffisant ces matelas c'est z
ponctuelles qui ont été données pour
faire face à la crise alors il ya deux
registres il ya deux temporalités
oui il faut absolument donner de quoi
rester la tête hors de l'eau
paquette personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
en grande difficulté dont il ya eu des
aides qui ont été apportés des aides
exceptionnelles pendant la crise
sanitaire 150 euros plus 100 euros par
enfant pour un certain nombre de ménages
mais elle était versée en une seule fois
si vous voulez et vous voyez on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui la situation dure
cette difficulté sociale dure
donc il faut absolument apporter des
aides de façon plus durable et puis il
ya des trous dans la raquette
même les aides qui ont été apportées
pendant la période de confinement ne
couvrait pas tout le monde les jeunes de
18 à 25 ans sans ressources parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le rsa ne sont pas concernés
par ces aides
les personnes seules qui sont au minimum
vieillesse par exemple donc il ya toute
une batterie de situations particulières
qui ne sont pas couverts par ces
difficultés par ces aides et qui sont en
grande difficulté aujourd'hui même chose
le ministre du logement ce matin a
annoncé une aide d'action logement donc
pas une aide de l'état mais d'action
logement pour les locataires en
difficulté il 150 euros pour les
chômeurs et les salariés en difficulté
versée pendant deux mois voilà donc sans
doute ça va couvrir une partie des
difficultés mais pas toutes donc c'est
un bon point c'est positif mais il faut
aller beaucoup plus on avait évalué nous
à peu près à 200 millions d'euros les
besoins de fonds dead pour payer le
loyer les charges à ceux qui rencontrent
des difficultés aujourd'hui qui demain
risquent l'expulsion mais là on est en
train de parler de mesures d'urgence ils
sont absolument indispensables parce
qu'il ya des gens qui souffrent
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya des gens qui
ont peur mais cette crise elle a rendu
encore plus visible une autre réalité
c'est que beaucoup même avec les
ressources issues du travail n'arrivent
pas à s'en sortir que les minima sociaux
sont pas suffisamment les montants des
minima sociaux ne sont pas suffisamment
élevée pour pallier aux moindres la
moindre difficulté à la moindre entorse
dans le budget de la famille au
quotidien donc à une réflexion beaucoup
plus profonde sur la protection sociale
sur les dispositifs d aide pour pouvoir
aider ceux qui ont rencontré un moment
dans leur vie des difficultés on va se
projeter sur l'avenir sur le monde
d'après mais encore je voudrais vous
entendre sur un certain nombre de
mesures que l'on pressent de la part du
gouvernement parce que vous l'avez dit
il y à ces aides ponctuelles
peut-être qu'ils sont déjà là qui sont
peut-être insuffisante et dans le même
temps on apprend aussi que le
gouvernement va certainement serré la
vis sur le chômage partiel ça pourrait
s'accompagner pour le salarié d'une
baisse de son salaire à 60% de son aide
contre 84%
aujourd'hui est ce que pour vous c'est
acceptable
est-ce que c'est pas normal aussi le
fait que le quoi qu'il en coûte
bien sûr d'eux
manuel macron des débuts trouve une fin
c'est compliqué votre question parce que
le quoi qu'il en coûte
il a trouvé une forme une réalité
pendant cette période de confinement oui
c'est à dire que on a mis à l'abri des
personnes sans domicile de façon
importante et la question de dire ok
mais finalement nous avons pris
conscience d'une urgence absolue à des
personnes à qui on disait restez chez
vous mais on n'a pas de sens on n'a pas
de domicile des personnes sans domicile
donc comment on pouvait faire donc on
s'est dit bon collectivement il faut une
réponse et le quoi qu'il en coûte a pu
jouer son rôle dans cette histoire
cercle ministre avait beaucoup plus de
latitude et donc on a pu travailler
ensemble associations etc
donc c'est quelque chose de positif mais
je vous pose la question sur laquelle
les problématiques des personnes sans
domicile
est-ce qu'on a simplement besoin d'un
toit sur la tête
l'hiver ou parce que il ya une crise
sanitaire majeure
danon et donc c'est là où on voit que
toutes les difficultés sociales toutes
les fragilités et sociales qui ont été
rendues encore plus visible pendant
cette crise elle nous interpelle
l'ensemble de la société
et c'est là où il faut se mettre autour
de la table pour dire les petits
salaires tous ces métiers indispensables
à la vie quotidienne
toutes les fragilités les personnes sans
domicile les personnes en situation de
pauvreté
les jeunes de moins de 25 ans qui n'ont
même pas droit aux 500 euros du rsa donc
il faut que cette période de crises
majeures auxquelles des réponses ont pu
être apportés en urgence donne lieu à
une transformation profonde de notre
société à partir de ces réalités
sociales à partir de ces difficultés et
de ses limites de notre système de
protection sociale
oui vous le dites il faut faire le bilan
de cette période de cette période du
confinement qui cela n'est pas une
surprise cela a été dit répété plusieurs
fois a été synonyme d'exacerbation des
inégalités c'est l'une des conclusions
du rapport annuel du défenseur des
droits qui a été remis cette semaine
écoutez à ce propos jacques toubon
la crise sanitaire elle a montré comment
beaucoup de choses que nous avons dit
que le défenseur des droits a dit depuis
des années et bien finalement elle était
un peu invisible et elles sont devenues
spectaculairement visibles les
inégalités sociales les inégalités
territoriales les inégalités en matière
d'éducation entre différentes familles
et différents enfants jacques toubon
parle de toute une palette d'inégalités
une des inégalités évidente et qui est
au coeur de l'action de la fondation
abbé pierre c'est bien sûr la question
du logement le confinement a mis en
lumière cette grande inégalité avez vous
le sentiment que l'exécutif a pris
aujourd'hui la mesure du problème et
aujourd'hui est résolu à l'it et à
lutter contre la question du mal
logement du nom logement de tous ces
problèmes liés au logement
non non non je crois que il ya une prise
de conscience de la société dans son
ensemble
mais il me semble que les exécutifs les
responsables politiques ont déjà
conscience du fait qu'il est près de
200000 personnes sans domicile fixe en
france qui à peu près 4 millions de mal
logés
on l'a vu par exemple au moment de la
catastrophe d'aubagne et bien sûr c'est
à dire pour les personnes vraiment des
images radieuses immeubles domaniaux
huit morts on assure on a vu aussi dans
la foulée qui avait cent mille logements
qui posait problème
pas forcément qui est menacé
d'effondrement mais dans lesquels les
personnes se réfugier faute d'autres
solutions et faute de retour de
ressources suffisantes pour se loger
dans d'autres dans d'autres logements
donc on le sait ça on le sait et c'est
là où la question le grand public mais
les pouvoirs publics ils connaissaient
je crois qu'il faut pas se tromper
et d'ailleurs le défenseur des droits le
dit il dit ça a rendu encore plus
visible des inégalités territoriales les
inégalités aussi on peut ajouter dans ce
rapport d'accès aux services publics
donc prenons l'exemple sur les
inégalités territoriales et des gens qui
ont eu faim pendant cette taille est de
confinement parce que les distributions
alimentaires ont dû réduire leur voilure
pendant un temps non par exemple on à
diffuser et distribuer des tickets
services pour que les gens puissent
s'alimenter porte quelque 7,6 qu'ils
aillent acheter eux mêmes du lait pour
les bébés de quoi se nourrir des
produits d'hygiène et bien on a vu que
dans les quartiers populaires des
populations qui étaient sur le fil passé
forcément grand je parle pas de
personnes sans domicile en grand prix
arrêtée mais les ressources très faible
et du coup une toute petite baisse
d'activité ou la perte de l'emploi fait
basculant à risque de pauvreté donc
c'est quelque chose qui nous concerne
tous et ça rejoint la question des
inégalités sans doute celle aussi de la
redistribution on va parler de la
question de la redistribution ou vous
disiez cette période anneaux nous
permettent en fait de faire le bilan de
réfléchir plus largement un monde
d'après juste avant le déconfinement la
fondation abbé pierre a fait partie des
signataires du pacte du pouvoir de vivre
qui a été notamment initié par nicolas
hulot dont on a pas mal parlé le ce
moment n'at-il pas été aussi rempli de
bonnes intentions de la part de tout le
monde sur la sur la suite sur le monde
d'après sur ce que cela doit-être est ce
que vous n'avez pas peur qu'aujourd'hui
et bien le soufflet et puissent très
facilement dégonfler est ce que ce n'est
pas déjà le cas
puis auprès de l'opinion publique
surtout de l'opinion publique je ne suis
pas sûr dans la mesure où toute prise de
conscience de la réalité la réalité
écologique on parle pas du pouvoir de
vivre de la réalité sociale de la
réalité par exemple de la situation des
hôpitaux laisse des traces alors ça veut
pas dire que changement il se fait de
manière radicale du jour au lendemain
mais ça laisse des traces
là où je suis moins tranquille c'est sur
la capacité de changer nos responsables
politiques
parce que on parle de structures les
choix moi j'ai aussi entendu des
représentants de l'exécutif aujourd'hui
dire mais finalement on va pas changer
de cap mais il faut justement qu'on
accélère non je suis désolé
prenons l'exemple des personnes sans
domicile ou des hôpitaux ce qui a été
dit sur les hôpitaux c'est que les
mesures pas seulement de ceux de ce
quinquennat de ce gouvernement
depuis longtemps on réduit la capacité
d'intervention de l'hôpital public et on
voit ce que ça a donné
et donc qu'il faut remettre des moyens
quand on voit augmenter le nombre de
personnes sans domicile fixe ou de mal
logés dans notre pays c'est exactement
la même chose
c'est à dire c'est les structures cd
dispositif c'est des réponses qui
diminue la voilure de ses réponses
diminue et à maman forcément il ya des
gens qui le paye
c'est à dire il ya des difficultés
et sociales qui se manifeste est là pour
pouvoir changer c'est à dire mettre au
coeur la question écologique met au
coeur la question sociale au coeur de
notre action politique collective les
souffrances de nos concitoyens
c'est une transformation profonde des
responsables politiques qui doivent
associer les acteurs comme les acteurs
du pack de pouvoir de vivre les
associations les syndicats les mutuelles
parce que on a cette visibilité on a
cette expertise de terrain et que nous
fassions ensemble des transformations
que nous appelons de nos voeux pour
demain parmi les transformations dont
vous parliez il ya question de la
redistribution des richesses meilleur un
meilleur partage de la richesse
il ya beaucoup de propositions en ce
moment à gauche notamment la taxe jean
valjean fait des émules pas sûr qu'elles
séduisent le gouvernement écoutez cet
échange entre sébastien jumel députés
communistes et la secrétaire d'état anya
ce panier une hache et il doit y
échanger lundi dans notre émission
auditions publiques écouter ce moment
new services publics sont allumés
l'injustice fiscale et est criante et
les inégalités sociales sont au rendez
vous mettons en place une taxe valjean
c'est à dire prenant pognon là où il est
ceux qui ont des yachts auront pas de
douche aux normes et peut-être
continueront à utiliser la rue haute et
finançons la relance et les services
publics et d'une certaine manière la
cohésion sociale nécessaire à la relance
avec une justice fiscale qui doit être
au rendez vous lorsqu'on lit l'histoire
des misérables jusqu'au bout et c'est
cette partie et cette facette de jean
valjean que je préfère il devient
monsieur madeleine il monsieur madeleine
ils montrent d'abord une fabrique de
verroterie puis il devient un industriel
reconnu et enfin il s'engage comme maire
auprès de ses compatriotes et c'est
comme ça qu'il fait en sorte que tous
les gens autour de lui et un emploi il y
est particulièrement attentif et cette
facette de jean valjean me semble
beaucoup plus intéressant alors que
l'idée de taxer systématiquement en
l'occurrence le capital c'est à dire ce
dont on a besoin
alors non on retrouve finalement un
débat qui est hantée diluvien sur le
partage des richesses avec eux d'un côté
en quelque sorte les défenseurs de ceux
qui veulent mieux partager le gâteau et
puis ceux qui disent ah non mais d'abord
on va attendre de faire grossir le
gâteau qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous
pensez du fait qu'on revienne
aujourd'hui à ce débat sur et bien la
redistribution des richesses c'est ça a
complètement mais il faut sortir
l'idéologie par contre il faut regarder
les choses telles qu'elles sont deux
choses
si on regarde ce qui s'est passé sur le
volet fiscal pendant ce quinquennat
suppression de l' isf mise en place de
la prélèvement forfaitaire unique on est
sur des milliards d'euros chaque année
quand on supprime la taxe d'habitation
d'abord pour 80% des ménages c'était la
promesse de campagne du candidat macron
pas de problème mais après en cours de
mandature on ajoute les 20 % les plus
aisés
ça coûte 10 milliards d'euros par an
d'accord donc c'est un choix moi je suis
pas sûr que les 20% qui paye cette taxe
d'habitation et demandé qu'on ne puis la
payer et ne peuvent ne puisse pas la
payer par contre nous avons eu des
baisses sur les apl cinq milliards dès
que vous décrivez là oui mais moi je
veux pas qu'on soit dans la théorie on a
parlé de souffrances on parle de
personnes sans domicile
on parle de précarité on parle de gens
qui sont en train de basculer donc il
faut regarder les chiffres
qu'est ce qui a été fait qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire
parce que parallèlement la baisser les
apl qui servent aux ménages pauvres et
modestes par exemple à hauteur de
plusieurs milliards par an donc le débat
c'est quel service public voulons-nous
hôpitaux police école logement réponse
sociale quels moyens avant nous ou pas
et est ce que tout le monde contribue à
sa juste mesure
et de ce point de vue là nous
effectivement on pense qu'il faut qu'on
ait un impôt plus évolutif
éventuellement rajouter une tranche plus
importante en eau des tranches les plus
élevées pour pouvoir mieux faire que la
contribution soit basée à la bonne
mesure de ce que chacun peut faire et
d'ailleurs
sincèrement il ya aujourd'hui des
personnes qui sont riches ou très aisés
qui disent mais moi c'est étonnant je
trouve que je suis pas beaucoup
fiscalité pas beaucoup d'impôts et alors
que la tva tout le monde la paye même
les plus pauvres sur le moindre le
moindre achat et l est pas spécialement
égalitaire si vous voulez donc il me
semble que sur ce sujet il faut
rationaliser sortir de l'idéologie mais
oui il va falloir mieux redistribuer
est-ce qu'il faut aussi pour vous
assurer un revenu pour les plus
vulnérables
est-ce qu'il faut revenir à cette idée
bien du revenu universel pour tous pour
le court alors pas pour tous pour ceux
qui en ont besoin
il ya deux logiques danseur nu le pour
tous et vous pour tout le monde qu'il a
discuté c'était cette porte absolument
si on pouvait juger au moins commencer
par ceux qui en ont besoin et le mettre
à un bon niveau
je disais tout à l'heure 540 euros le
rsa nous pensons nous les associations
de lutte contre l'exclusion qu'il
faudrait vraiment arriver au même niveau
que le rmi à l'époque par rapport aux
salaires on va dire ou au smic c'est à
peu près 50 % du smic donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut significativement rehaussé ce
minimum en fait ce revenu minimum donc
oui il faudrait forme là dessus et puis
il faut l'ouvrir aux jeunes de 18 à 25
ans c'est vraiment une mesure urgente
immédiatement je rappelle si vous êtes
en rupture familiale que vous avez 20
ans ne voulait pas de boulot que vous
n'avez rien c'est zéro euro dead
donc là on est sur quelque chose de
totalement incohérent de totalement
indigne et ça c'est la première des
mesures à mettre en oeuvre la en sortie
de confinement il sait pas qu'il ya une
grande inquiétude sur la jeunesse
c'est ce qui expliquait par exemple
l'économiste laurence boone de l' ocde
elle a dit bien oui les jeunes sont ils
vont être les premières victimes parce
que le tourisme l'événement salé sport
publiques ce sont des secteurs qui vont
vraiment être en berne
et ce sont des secteurs qui embauchent
justement pour grande proportion des
jeunes et souvent des jeunes moins
qualifiés et pour eux ça va être très
difficile de retrouver un sujet majeur
d'inquiétude les jeunes c'est un taux de
chômage deux fois supérieur à la moyenne
en france
c'est un nombre de personnes sans
domicile deux fois plus élevé que la
moyenne des autres générations en france
donc cette c'était dans la situation
avant la crise sanitaire
vous l'avez dit c'est des centaines de
milliers de jeunes qui aujourd'hui ont
perdu leur emploi et des centaines de
milliers jeunes qui vont entrer sur le
marché d'emploi à la rentrée de
septembre
là il faut vraiment mettre le paquet
pour ne pas faire démarrer trop
difficilement évidemment toute cette
génération mais c'est pas un sujet qui
est seulement d'actualité
c'est un sujet qui dure depuis longtemps
et qui impose la mise en place de
dispositifs vraiment ambitieux en
quelques secondes
qu'est ce que vous attendez du discours
d' emmanuel macron le président de la
république qui doit s'exprimer dimanche
beaucoup beaucoup mais que le scénario
de la reconstruction du périmètre de la
reconstruction se fasse avec nous avec
les organisations du pack du pouvoir de
vivre les associations les syndicats les
mutuelles pour que on recommence pas
comme avant se décide pas à quelques-uns
ou avec une lecture seulement macro que
justement on tire les enseignements de
cette crise et aussi de tout ce que l'on
voit depuis des années nous les
associations les syndicats les ai donc
on mobilise j'allais dire le patronat
tout le monde autour de la table pour
dire on va faire des compromis et on va
traiter la question sociale écologique
et démocratique une mobilisation qui
englobe tout le monde merci beaucoup
christophe robert d'avoir répondu à mes
questions pour ce grand entretien